lisa is with us in Arizona hi Lisa
welcome to the Dave Ramsey show well
thanks it's great to talk to you
YouTube what's up I'm an odd situation
I've been a stay-at-home mom for 12
years and finalizing a divorce and in
the divorce I'm not getting anything but
I am getting the house so the net
proceeds from the house will be all mine
it's about $300,000 and I have some
ideas on how to allocate that and I
thought I'd cross it by you so I don't
have any debt leaving this divorce good
mm-hmm and is there any debt in the
marriage there is but that's part of our
divorce settlement is that I mean it's
so little we're good at we're good about
not having debt so okay but your name
your name is on it but he's being told
to pay it in the divorce the debt my
name is not on it
no I mean it sort of but not sorta it
either is or it isn't did you sign for
the debt no okay this is not a sorta I
mean if you saw because the mortgage
right but we're sewing now oh I got you
okay yeah the other debts though you do
not have your name on at all correct
good okay I'm back with you then so
you're getting three and a 50,000 bucks
in your how old um almost 50 okay kids
at home yes I have so I have two young
kids and so in this step in the divorce
I will be getting my monthly expenses
will be short by $3,000 because his
support will not beat what I spend now
so I my idea was that I would use some
of the money from the house to meet this
deficit some to put into emergency fund
and some to put into retirement okay and
how old are the kids I have a 12 year
old and a six year old okay and and what
is the amount of the our monthly support
mm oh yeah okay and so you figure your
budgets for part five yeah
okay and you're gonna rent a house I'm
currently renting a house yeah okay and
that is included in your $5,000 budget
yeah hmm I the only thing I don't like
about your plan is that I don't like a
deficit like this that doesn't have an
end to it okay you know what I mean
you're going back to school I'm gonna
try to go back to school I mean I didn't
sign up yet because I want to cross this
Bayou but yeah but obviously I have to
get work so that would be part of it I
can make a whole lot of money to be able
to work for so long I got you I got you
so so you're thinking of going back to
school to study what I don't know be a
nurse I'm not sure yet I got you okay
how fresh is all this divorce it's it's
we just submitted though I mean it's now
okay so you just come to agreement on
these terms recently correct okay I'm
sorry
so we're a painful time all right so
here's the thing I don't want you to
have a $3,000 burn rate and burn through
the only money you've got mm-hmm
so we need an end to this and you don't
have to decide today but you just need
to give yourself a deadline that says
I'm going back to school study something
and start my career by X okay yeah two
years whatever something like that right
and if you got an undergrad already yeah
okay so if you went back into the
two-year nursing program or something as
an example okay that would be you know
then we've got 36,000 $72,000 that's
going to burn for two years that you're
$3,000 burn rate mm-hmm okay you can't
keep going along on that with a three
only 350 grand so no I wouldn't put any
into retirement until you've made the
transition into your new career
mm-hmm okay just let it sit there this
is this money's to help you with your
encore you know when the curtain goes
down curtain comes back up and take a
bow your encore oh this is it baby
this is it this is your encore this is
your the last act is the best act and
this is yours so whatever it is you want
to you get to do it now and the good
news is you've got the money to take
care of your family and fund your
education if you don't get anything out
of this but that with us three and fifty
thousand I'll be okay because you're
gonna be okay for the rest of your life
if you get yourself in a position to
produce an income but that's what that's
what we've got to get to and I just
don't want this money to burn up because
in the process of emotionally healing
from as much pain as you've been through
you delay too much your encore
I know yeah it's easy to do emergency
money I think that's in critical cause I
think the whole thing is emergency money
I mean that's really what I'm saying
it's it's an emergency to temporarily
feed the deficit the burn rate it's an
emergency for you to get back into
school and then you've got a portion of
it that is truly for rainy days but I
mean you can carve that up but if you
said okay two years is my deal
that I need a seventy two thousand
dollar account over here that's my burn
account I've got over here I've got to
have a thirty thousand dollars from my
emergency fund and you know that leaves
me a hundred and fifty thousand to get
through school what you should be able
to do and come out with some money I'd
like for you to come out school and have
a hundred grand left it sounds like you
can yeah I think I counted it yeah and
at that point at that point I would
think about investing but you might as
you go through I mean you're right now
in the worst of the pain so it's them
even though we're having a really good
conversation and you're obviously very
bright and very articulate your brain is
working as poorly right now as it's
going to I mean it's just in survival
mode no I know you're you're in just
you're just hanging on it's everything's
a raw nerve and so you know you'll be
thinking clearer in four months is what
I'm saying
and but when I get this money and they
put it in my hand do I park it in a
money market at a bank okay then don't
touch it I need to touch it for the demo
except for the deficit
I mean you don't need to go buy
something to feel better be careful
guard yourself no I don't I don't I
don't have you guys are you are you in a
good church but you're handsome I'm not
in the church have you got someone in
your life that will get in your face if
you start doing stupid stuff
oh yeah that's a plan that's why we're
not dead no I said have you got someone
in your life that will get in your face
do you have someone from an
accountability standpoint that you can
use right now just to make sure I don't
think you're going to I don't hear any
of this but if anybody's gonna screw up
big time it's when they're right here
you know yeah you're at a vulnerable
time and I'm trying to put a wall around
you to protect you and sometimes protect
you from you a little bit and that's all
I'm saying
so if you got a really good girlfriend
or a mom it's a little bossy or
something like that this is a good time
to have them know what's going on and
just go aiya promise if it's over a ten
thousand dollar expense to talk to this
person of wisdom first and that's your
accountability person part person a
person of wisdom the person of wisdom
loves you with all their heart but will
tell you the cold unvarnished truth
because they love you they will not say
oh yeah that's smart and then go home
and go that's a dumbest thing I've heard
no they will just tell you that's stupid
don't do that you're hurting your brains
are not working don't do that don't do
that don't do that I have an idea to
that you might start a business I don't
know I'm gonna send you a copy of
Christy Wright's book just in case it's
called business boutique equipping women
to make money doing what they love and
you've got a little capital if you want
to start a little small thing you've
always had a dream of that that might be
cheaper than nursing school and they
might make you more money I don't know
it's whatever you want to do with your
life I'm not trying to tell you have to
but four months from now you might be
able to breathe a little bit more and
that might make a lot more sense for you
so hey thanks for the call open phones a
triple eight eight two five five two two
five you jump in we'll talk about your
life and your money man I'll tell you
going through a divorce is hard
going through the illness of a loved one
it's hard going through the loss of a
loved one is hard and if you're not very
careful we all have a tendency to buy
things to make ourselves feel better be
careful when you're in those painful
times retail therapy is not a cute joke
it's a stupid idea